hey guys it's Wednesday May 27th i'm
your host Mary Tish and this is gamespot
news Jess McDonald is gone look at me
i'm your host now I'm just kidding we're
friends first up if you like freebies as
much as I do you're probably frothing at
the mouth for next week that's when
PlayStation Plus members get metal gear
solid ground zeroes for free here's the
lineup PlayStation 4 owners get the
amazing metal gear solid 5 ground zeroes
skulls of the Shogun bonafide edition
super exploding zoo and future idiom EP
deluxe PlayStation 3 owners get call of
juarez gunslinger and cloudberry Kingdom
and finally PlayStation Vita owners get
super exploding Zoo which due to cross
save will work with anyone who has a ps4
all six games are fries 13 Tuesday June
second replacing existing set of
freebies for May so if you haven't
downloaded Hohokam yet for the love of
all that's weird do it now there's been
more than a few game delays already this
year and that's prompting PlayStation
President Andrew house to admit that the
Playstations first party line up is
looking a little friend speaking today
during Sony's annual investor day
conference PlayStation President Andrew
house acknowledged the PlayStation 4's
first party line up for this year is
looking a little sparse we are working
very hard to continue very strong
support from third-party publishers and
developers House said our first party
line up is a little sparse this year so
I think this place is an even greater
emphasis on getting good third-party
support to high-profile first party ps4
games recently delayed 2 2016 including
uncharted 4 a thief's end and the new
ratchet & clank this year's remaining
ps4 first party lineup includes titles
like tearaway unfolded and god of war 3
remastered as well as whatever
super-secret Sony titles that might be
announced at e3 this year I'm looking at
you Last Guardian now a few skins might
not be the best way to get you to
pre-order a game what if i told you
pre-ordering batman arkham knight would
get you the skin from Batman Beyond
debatably the best interpretation of a
Batman series
ever debatably spotted on the game steam
product page is Gotham's future skin
pack including a skin inspired by Frank
Miller's the dark knight returns and
more importantly one from the animated
show Batman Beyond in which a teenaged
Batman in a futuristic Gotham City is
guided by an elderly Bruce Wayne it's
seriously the best if you haven't seen
it go check it out another preorder
bonus is a DLC mission that lets you
play as Harley Quinn this bonus is
available across all platforms batman
arkham knight launches jun 23 you have
until then to scrape up enough money for
that sweet sweet skin oh I can't wait to
lotion up that skin and wear it to
dinner so what goes together better than
macaroni and cheese spaghetti and
meatballs or lamb and tuna fish well
it's probably Lego and minecraft it's
nothing more than rumor right now but
images for a Minecraft inspired Lego
product have appeared on eurobricks
forum the image features the tagline
explore discover create seemingly
indicating that Warner Brothers and TT
games are creating experience similar to
Minecraft which itself is heavily
influenced by Lego the image does not
feature any logos hinting at what
platform the game may be available in or
for any sort of release window gamespot
is contacted Warner Brothers for a
comment or more let me know how they
dodge that question so Lego makes a game
inspired by Minecraft after minecraft
makes a game inspired by Lego the circle
is complete finally if you purchased
Ultra Street Fighter 4 on PlayStation 4
this week you might have noticed that
you regretted making that purchase
initial reports are indicating that the
game is basically interactive garbage
citing choppy menu screens visual bugs
blurry textures sound bugs missing sound
effects moves not working as they should
and the most unforgivable of all
fighting game offenses input lag Sony's
Gio Corsi the director of third-party
production and developer relations says
the company is currently exploring patch
options and fix all the current issues
and hopefully at octodad is a playable
character a girl can dream
so that's all the game news we have for
you today but be sure to check back
tomorrow we'll have more gaming news
right here on gamespot
[Music]